[Music]
foreign
the top business door is live from the
Sky News City Studio
unlocking the economic potential of
artificial intelligence we hear from the
new managing director of Google UK and
Ireland in her first broadcast interview
in the role
online electricals retailer AO World
returns to profit despite a drop in
sales
and the world's top 1000 banks are named
find out which UK lenders made the cut
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live a
business life lydian King before we get
going some breaking news that sir
reached Us in the last couple of moments
the competition and markets Authority
has just find Leicester City Football
Club up to 880 000 pounds that's after
it admitted anti-competitive arrangement
with JD Sports more on that as we get it
now the artificial to artificial
intelligence is one of the most profound
technology changes of our lifetime and
has the potential to deliver a boost
worth 400 billion pounds to the UK
economy by the end of the decade that's
according to an economic impact report
published today by Google but it says
that can only happen if the UK raises
its research and development investment
builds greater Computing capacity and
enhances digital skills I mean speaking
with Debbie Weinstein she's Google's UK
and Ireland managing director in her
first broadcast interview since she took
the job and began by asking how the
company arrived at that 400 billion
pound figure
AI is the most profound technology that
I think we're working on today and it is
not just a profound technology for
technology but also has a huge
opportunity for the UK you cited the 400
billion pound figure that's the economic
impact we think this can have by 2030 so
actually growing the economy each year
by 2.6 percent uh which is a huge
Improvement in terms of the growth
trajectory that the country is currently
on
for that to happen though the UK will
need to invest more in research and
development invest more in skills I mean
these are unfortunately things where the
UK lags a lot of its peer economies
we do think that r d investment will be
key I think skills investment is also
going to be critical uh we actually just
trained our 1 millionth Learner in the
UK around digital skills and I think
making sure everyone can participate in
the Advent of not just AI but the
overall digital skills transformation is
going to be critical to unrealize
realizing this opportunity now you also
note that the UK will require more in in
computing power as it were why do we lag
other economies in this respect right
now
I think computing power actually quite
strong and I think we need to continue
our investment in this area I think it
is a AI certainly from a technical
standpoint requires a lot of compute
power so we'll need to remain rigorous
in terms of our investment there
but why is the UK behind some of its
peers
currently actually the UK is in a pretty
good spot in terms of our compute
capacity and I think the question is can
we keep pace and continue investing at
that level it's going to be critical for
us to continue to have a leadership
position in AI there's a big debate as
to whether AI is going to create or
destroy jobs are we framing the question
in the right way
I think jobs is a really important topic
for us to be talking about I do think
there will be some jobs that are
fundamentally transformed and the
majority of jobs will fundamentally
change in terms of how they use AI in
their in the work that they do every day
personally I'm using um kind of
autocorrect and all the techniques in
Gmail to be faster and more productive
in the work I do every single day there
will be jobs that are lost but I think
the bigger opportunity will be the next
Generation jobs that are created and
that's why we're so focused on the
skills agenda and making sure everyone
has the skills they need to succeed in
this new wave of technologically abled
growth obviously though AI is going to
render some tasks and some jobs obsolete
I mean what sort of things should my
kids be studying at school right now
what sort of career should they be
looking at if they're not going to get
swept away by this technology well I
think it's actually getting that balance
rate between having that kind of
well-rounded education that helps you
understand the possibility of Technology
but the application to whatever you're
passionate about I think AI is
fundamentally going to transform
everything that we're working on today
and make our lives better
um and I think those that know how to
use those tools the AI driven tools for
Innovation and creativity are really
going to be the ones that are going to
succeed in the future
what sort of things are you looking for
in Google UK and Ireland now as regards
new recruits
oh well we're always looking for for
great talent at Google
um and I we are fortunate to be a great
employer here we have actually 6 500
folks uh based in the UK across a
variety of areas so we have 50 of our
staff are actually in technical roles so
product and engineering and 50 of our
staff are in sales and marketing General
administrative kind of roles so there's
a huge uh range of career options at
Google here in the UK I mean that's what
really interests me about your career
because you started out as of anchor at
Goldman Sachs you've set up your own
business you've worked at the likes of
Viacom and Unilever I mean yours is not
what you might call a traditional Tech
background
uh well thank you for setting up on my
background that is true I've Had A
diversity of experiences I actually
think diverse experiences make for an
interesting career and I think I've
learned different things from each of
those experiences that make me a better
professional today so certainly I would
encourage your kids as they're thinking
of setting out on their Journeys to be
less focused on the specific job but
more about the set of skills that they
want to assemble from different
experiences they might have
why do you think people are skeptical
though about the transformative
potential of AI I mean for example
Jeffrey Hinton sometimes called the
Godfather of AI I mean he's just left a
senior role at Google
yes I think that AI because it is such a
profound technology I think the
opportunity for it to be incredibly
powerful in solving some of society's
biggest problems climate change Health
um you know we just launched a tool that
helps you anticipate floods and the
impact that can happen in communities
around the world that's incredible at
the same time we know that powerful
technology we need to be really
responsible about how it's deployed so
at Google we take this balanced approach
to being both bold and responsible at
the same time we launched AI principles
many years ago that actually govern the
way we are deploying Ai and we're really
rolling it out in a very measured
cautious way to make sure those benefits
come forward that 400 billion pound
economic value for the UK that we see
um so available for us by 2030 but at
the same time do it in a responsible way
the online electrical Goods retailer air
world has returned to profit despite a
drop in sales after removing costs from
the business and closing its loss making
German business well the company in
which Mike Ashley's phrases group has
built a 22 stake reported an operating
profit of 13 million pounds for the year
to the end of March that compared to the
loss of eight million pounds during the
previous 12 months well joining me now
is John Roberts he's the founder and
chief executive of AO World John good to
see you this morning uh one of the big
changes you made during the last year of
course was to introduce delivery charges
to what extent did that hit your sales
volumes
yeah so it did affect sales in in those
single digits uh but and really what
we're delighted with that is is the
evidence that customers are delighted to
take the quality of service that we
deliver for them uh because delivery
isn't free and so we look at it as an
overall basket of the total amount that
customers pay
which product lines have done best over
the last 12 months and which have done
not so well
well so so the the most resilient area
of our business is in the core major
domestic appliance market and so if you
think about that as need over want if
you will but if your fridge freezer
breaks then you're likely to need a new
one rather than want a new one and so
most of what we sell is an essential
item and doesn't sit in that
discretionary piece uh so and so that's
why the performance of the business
through difficult economic times has
been so solid
the resilience of consumer spending has
really taken a lot of people by surprise
why do you think it has held up
well I mean if you look at employment
data you know clearly we've got macro
challenges and households have got
choices to make but we still have very
strong employment data so it's people
choosing again on on those things of
need versus one and it's it's a pretty
fast changing picture on the different
things that households are having to
deal with whether that is you know not
so long ago it was energy it's now
moving to mortgage rates uh so uh so
from our point of view within that you
know as the most trusted electrical
retailer in the UK it is just about us
bringing those customers the best prices
all the time uh so that on those
non-discretionary essential items they
get the best deals
obviously 1.7 million households are
going to come off their existing
mortgage deals over the next 12 months
does that concern you clearly that's
going to eat into their spending power
yeah for sure I mean we're not going to
be immune there's no doubt about that
but one of the interesting trends that
we are seeing actually is particularly
coming off the back of the energy crisis
is that actually as people are having to
make those choices uh as the the
household budgets get squeezed they're
making more considered medium-term
decisions so actually one of the trends
that we are seeing is that people are
investing more on average product prices
uh so that they get a better product
that's generally more energy efficient
now so it costs them Less in the medium
term so there's some very interesting
different dynamics that are coming as
households get squeezed where
historically that might have caused
households to trade down what we're
actually seeing now on a product value
is that the households are trading up
obviously at the beginning of the uh
last Financial year there were a lot of
supply chain issues with which uh the
entire industry was grappling are those
really uh abated away now
yeah as far as we're concerned you know
we consider covid uh and all its impacts
in terms of the supply chains pretty
well in trench uh there's sorts of
things that are stocking some things
that have reverted back to the way that
they work uh but I think that's our
that's our responsibility to deal with
on behalf of customers all customers
care about is that they get amazing
choice and great prices when they get on
the website and the rest is for us to
deal with and what he's seeing right now
in terms of product price inflation
no we're not seeing a lot of lots of
product price inflation as I say the the
inflation is a consumer choice for
customers to invest in
uh and more expensive product that has a
better energy rating that actually saves
the money in the medium term is what
we're seeing
all right John there's so much more I
wanted to ask you we're out of time I'm
afraid thanks for spend the time today
that's good to see you
some other news stories for you now and
new car registrations in the UK jumped
by 25.8 percent in June that was the
11th consecutive month of growth the
Society of motor manufacturers and
Traders says it's down to the resolution
of supply chain issues and pent-up
Demand Being met Electric Vehicle
registrations Rose by almost 40 percent
and now make up 17.9 of the total Market
Financial conduct Authority has
confirmed for the first time it is
investigating whether the hedge fund
manager Chris bin Odie is a fit and
proper person to work in financial
services in a letter to the treasury
select committee Nicole rothy the FCA
chief executive confirmed the regulator
had launched an ongoing investigation
into Mr Odie and his firm ODI Asset
Management two years ago well Mr Odie
was ousted from The Firm last month
after the financial times reported on a
number of allegations of sexual
misconduct which he denies
the vehicle rent rental group red
Northgate said this morning that demand
was still outstripping supplies it
reported record results the company
whose importance in the white van rental
market means it's seen as a barometer of
small business activity reported a
pre-tax profit of 178.7 million pounds
for the year to the end of April that
was up 35 on the previous 12 months or
red Northgate which imply employs more
than 7 000 people and which operates a
fleet of more than 130 000 owned and
leased vehicles said it continued to
enjoy robust demand
the shares of the building material
supplier Sig fell by nearly 12 today
after it warned that this year's profits
would be at the lower end of market
expectations Sig which used to be called
Sheffield insulation group said that
sales for the first six months of the
year had come in at 1.4 billion pounds
that was unchanged on the same period
last year it said market conditions have
been notably weaker in Poland and
Ireland over the period as a whole while
it had seen a notable softening in
demand in France and Germany during the
last two months
senior Chinese officials said today that
the country's export controls on Metals
used in making semiconductors are just a
start where zhangao a former Vice
Commerce Minister told the China Daily
newspaper that countries should brace
for more should they continue to
pressure China he was speaking after
China's decision on Monday to place
controls on exports of some gallium and
germanium products which are used to
make chips and which are also used in
the manufacturing of electric vehicles
and Fiber Optic Cables will a move time
to coincide with America's 4th of July
celebrations have pushed up prices as
companies rush to secure supplies
foreign
markets in the Asia Pacific region
suffered losses overnight following
signs of a Slowdown in China's Services
sector he can give us a picture all of
the main indices in negative territory
European equities have also traded to
the downside this morning that's a
picture in Continental Europe right now
talking points this morning include
Volvo cars the shares there up nearly
two percent in Stockholm that's after it
reported a 33 rise in June Car Sales
well here in London ftse 100 also
negative territory currently off by half
of one percent in a broad base sell-off
among leading Blue Chip fallers right
now as legal in general it's off some
two percent that's on news of a change
in accounting rules which will clip
profits this year by more than expected
some of the big China exposed stocks are
also trading to the downside most
notably Prudential or finally two and
three quarter percent right now there
aren't too many gainers to mention in
the main index but the educational
publisher Pearson the shares up there by
just over two and a quarter percent on
positive broker comment outside at the
footsie the engineering contractor
Keller group is ahead by Sun 12 on a
trading update right now while the
drinks group CNC they're the people
behind tenants lager they're up by
nearly two percent after the fund
manager Artemis raised its stake in the
company on the Foreign Exchange Market
well the pound has given up some of uh
Tuesday's gains right now though
actually not really it's more or less
unchanged right now against both the
dollar and the Euro single currency not
really much moved either against the
Greenback the oil price has been on the
move today though it's slightly slipped
after yesterday's strong gains uh that's
uh on demand concerns rearing their ugly
head once again a barrel of breakthrough
right now will set you back 75.99 a
barrel that's of a third of one percent
will joining me now is Rachel winter
partner at kilikin Co Rachel good to see
you this morning what's caught your eye
in the markets today probably illegal in
general so I know the shares are down
this morning that is because of a change
in accounting rules that changes how
they show their profits but along with
that update there was a nice trading
update that said how the rest of the
business is doing and they have
experienced a very big increase in
demand for annuities so that annuities
business is up 27 compared to last year
and I think that's really because of the
the attractiveness of annuity rates
these days so annuity rates they tend to
be based roughly around the 10-year
guilt yield in 2020 that went down to
about 0.2 percent now it's up at 4.4 so
much more attractive and therefore not
surprising we're seeing an increase in
demand for annuities yeah good value I
mean obviously legal's uh sir Nigel
Wilson's about to step down us uh a CEO
after a very long nurse didn't they
you're anticipating any major strategic
changes from his successor no not at the
moment I don't think him stepping down
is a big surprise so I'd like to think
they've got a good succession plan in
place yeah Antonio osumo is we've had
him on the program in the past and
hopefully see him before too long what
about some of these mid-250 statements a
fairly sort of active day in the mid
caps there a few things going on yes
perhaps we could look at numas so this
is an investment Bank focusing on UK mid
caps a bit of a pessimistic statement
this morning so they said there's been a
real lack of mergers and Acquisitions in
the UK over the last year as we know but
that will have impacted numerous
revenues but it's a bit ironic because
numis itself is actually in the process
of being taken over by Deutsche Bank
absolutely and a deal that really did it
has to be said catch people by surprise
around here it did I personally was very
surprised but the deal is scheduled to
go through by the end of this year and
because that is scheduled to go through
we haven't seen much of a movement in
New Mexico this morning whereas
otherwise I think we might have seen
some weakness yeah did they say much
about the pipeline because it was quite
interesting looking at some of the other
trading updates from their peers I mean
pure hunt recently said they were
beginning to see signs of life again in
the market numerous actually I felt they
implied the pipeline was quite weak so
they've suggested that people are still
quite concerned about the macroeconomic
Outlook and that's really damaging
confidence and putting people off from
going through with big deals well you
mentioned the macro we got the latest
purchasing managers index survey data
for the services sector out this morning
here in the UK I mean it's still growing
but growth appears to have slowed down
how worried should people be about that
I don't think it's surprising I think we
have seen a big increase in wages which
perhaps has caused these Services sector
to slow a little bit but the PMI number
is still well above 50 and that means
that people do believe the sector is
expanding so it's not all bad news yeah
it was quite interesting listening to
John Roberts from mayor World them he's
he still sees plenty of optimism out
there plenty of resilience in consumer
spending he does and I think some of his
comments had some quite positive read
across for other sectors so in
particular he said some things like
shipping costs are really starting to
normalize so that should be a benefit to
a number of other sectors all right
Rachel we've got to leave it there
always good to see you thanks for
joining me
still to come here on business life the
banker magazine publishes its list of
the world's top Banks but only one UK
institution makes the top ten find out
who it is
[Music]
we're about a month into the offensive
now
um and it's going okay
um you know there's quite a lot of
messages coming out from president
zielinski and others just kind of I
think canceling caution you know it
takes time it's going it's going okay
but it's not going fast and all you know
I think nor should we expect it to be
you know the ukrainians are trying to
attack through very very difficult
Russian defenses and it's it's slow and
costly progress well I think what what
you're seeing is across the front the
very long Frontage the Ukrainian forces
are they're pressing they're probing
they are making gains Hannah Malia who's
the Ukrainian defense minister Deputy
defense minister said yesterday they
took about nine square kilometers the
day before I mean that's a small amount
of terrain but it is forward movement
but I think what's actually going on is
is the thing you don't see and that is
kind of preparation in depth so lots of
and we saw this last year as well where
the ukrainians will be trying to prepare
uh in depth so they'll be trying to
destroy Russ Russian Logistics their
Commander control which will make it
easier when they do break through well
the cost of human life you know we've
heard it from a number of people
recently just to again to manage our
expectations General milley the American
chairman of the Joint Chiefs said only a
couple of days ago you know this this is
this is costly Warfare and none of us
should ever lose sight of that you know
when we're when we're kind of looking on
our Twitter feeds or whatever you know
the reality is for the soldiers on the
front line This is brutally difficult
I'm increasingly reminded of my own
experiences in in mosul when uh we we or
the Iraqis liberated mosul uh and and
the Offensive start with great fans
there in the worlds get gays but the
reality is it takes a long time it took
nine months for the Iraqis to liberate
one city and they did that with the
worlds or the West Air power and support
and of course the ukrainians don't have
as much air power as they need
[Music]
foreign
Fly Emirates fly better
welcome back HSBC Remains the only
European Bank in the top 10 in the
annual top 1000 World Banks ranking
compiled by the banker magazine it's the
12th consecutive year that HSBC has been
the only European lender in the top 10
which is topped by Industrial and
Commercial Bank of China which also
includes JP Morgan Chase Bank of America
and Citigroup well if the UK Banks
Barclays fell three places to 27th
Lloyds fell by 10 places to 52nd
Standard Chartered dropped five places
to 56th and that West fell by eight
spots to 61st which you want to be nice
enjoyment night she's editor of the
banker Joy good to see you this morning
I mean it really is striking that the
rankings are just dominated at the top
echelons by China and the US yes they
they just keep growing and especially
the Chinese Banks of course this year
what we've seen across the top 1000
World Banks ranking which is ranked by
tier one capital is across the aggregate
we've actually seen a bit of a
contraction so even the Chinese Banks a
bit of a fall however that was mostly
due to the strong U.S dollar
so if the Chinese Banks if we looked at
it and we and the ranking is in U.S
dollars but if we looked at it in one in
actual fact the Chinese Banks would have
grown by about eight percent however
they fell by about one percent
um but again you know in terms of the
double-digit growth that we've seen
across the Chinese banks in recent years
this is a bit of a uh you know a come
down that's interesting and just to uh
tier one Capital there that's the amount
of capital that banks have to keep on
their balance sheets yeah it's the core
Capital so it looks at the total assets
that the bank has but then also looks at
how what how risky those assets are and
this is sort of the core so if something
goes wrong the core capital is what's
going to come in to help it's very
interesting if we'd been having this
conversation 15 years ago the UK lenders
would have been far far up the rankings
I mean they're all rather diminished
posts the financial crisis aren't they
yeah that's true but you know every
decade you sort of see a bit of a
different change so the bankers ranking
has been going since 1970 and at that
point American banks are on top and then
there was the French banks in the 80s
the Japanese banks in the 90s Etc and
then the Americans but the Chinese banks
have dominated ICBC for example has been
in the top spot now for 11 years so
that's a record-breaking well at least
you don't feel obliged like the Sunday
Times rich list to come up with a new
leader every year no no no no no one
thing that caught my eye is the fact
that UK banks in aggregate have
increased their employee numbers over
the last 12 months I think that will
surprise people given the rate at which
they've been closing branches yeah it's
quite interesting and that we saw that
across the top six UK Banks then in
actual fact they the employees have
actually grown by about 0.6 which is not
a lot to be honest but at the same time
it does Buck a trend and then we but
across the past decade you've seen a 23
decrease in employee numbers so the
longer a trend is for a big decrease
actually now you've also compiled a
listing of the biggest loss makers in
the uh over the last 12 months I mean no
surprise to see vtb of Russia at the top
of the list but there are quite a few
Challenger banks in there the likes of
kalana banker monzo and metrobank should
should people be worried about that uh I
think it's interesting because for
example new bank and monzo it's the
first time in the top 1000 so they're
building out their core Capital their
tier one capital and things but they're
still seeing uh as you say the losses
um so yeah I think we need to to say
that a lot of those banks are really
focused on client acquisition maybe
prioritize that above profits but
obviously they want to turn that around
in future now obviously the UK lenders
run in the firing line at the moment for
not passing on the full extent of
increases in bank rate to save us but
actually you've come up with um some
evidence that actually their costs in
paying depositors has risen quite
sharply
um well what we see is that in actual
fact when you look at net interest
income it actually sees you know
obviously it's growing because interest
rates are going up so you see that
growing but in actual fact when you look
at income expenses that's actually going
up at a much higher rate and so even
though the it's still dominant in terms
of the net income interest rise using
what we've seen is that there's expenses
which is coming down to things like
deposits but then also when banks have
to go into the market and actually get
funding from the market so those costs
you know are quite uh are going up quite
substantially that's fascinating do you
think they're going to ride out this
current storm yes I think so and again
the strong dollar also had an impact on
the UK banks in general
um so you just think to yourself you
know like except for HSBC and Standard
Chartered which reports in dollars uh
you know the the pound depreciated
against the US dollar by about tile
percent in 2022 which is the year that
the ranking is based on
year-end results and so you know to be
honest they haven't done that badly in
comparison when you put it into context
all right Joy could leave it there good
to talk to you again thanks so much Ian
that's it for me for now I'll be back
with the afternoon edition of business
live at half past four hope very much to
see you then in the meantime do stay
tuned after this short break Jane sucker
is coming up it's obviously pmqs today
but there's no Rishi sunak he's at the
NHS service we'll have more on that
after this short break see you later
cheerio
great thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you